what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation been a while since we've
done a morning trailer but we got
ourselves an official one for a film
that i'm already really looking forward
to just because of the director and the
cast involved and that is babylon john
good morning to you how are you good
morning to you sir i am doing i'm doing
swell how are you i'm doing well john
thank you for asking chum
time pal
brad pitt margot robbie and toby mcguire
under the direction of damian chazelle
what more can you ask for ladies and
gentlemen leave a like let's get to it
[Applause]
what about you
sorry
if you could go anywhere in the whole
world where would you go
i always wanted to be part of something
bigger
[Applause]
i love that answer something that lasts
that means something something more
important than life yes
it's written in this stars i am a star
if i had money i would only spend it on
things that were fun you know not boring
things like taxes i'm just waiting for
everyone to party forever
oh man
[Applause]
oh my god damn
when i first moved to l.a signs on all
the doors said no actors are dogs
allowed i changed that
and now y'all ready for something
different
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
look up and say
eureka i'm not alone
get
it oh my god
[Music]
oh my goodness i'm in so much trouble
manny
we have to live now
what i do means
you thought this town needed you
it's bigger than you
i
don't know
it's the most magical place in the world
[Applause]
lift that up oh you big mr man who wants
to see me fight a [ __ ] snake
[Music]
oh that looks like a christmas movie for
you that's an oscar contender right
there that's one of those movies we're
like slide it in before the end of the
year
we need to get an oscar nomination
oscars love a movie about hollywood wow
that looks
insane oh yes absolutely insane
i loved it not even sure exactly what
it's about
it's just about chaos and and and
debauchery and excess all i heard about
it was what was available on the
wikipedia page was that it takes place
during the jazz age from the transition
of silent films to talkies say easily
capturing the the mad cap debauchery of
hollywood from back then like that
instant transition but it does feel like
that you know chazelle he became really
famous with the movie whiplash and it
seems like music is going to be such an
integral piece see la la land obviously
the way he uses music to really help
tell the stories it feels like that's
going to be so essential of this film
that feels a bit like a
um you know
once upon a time in hollywood ironically
with brad pitt and marco robbie yeah
yeah
meets uh a scorsese flavor with uh a
little bit of that wolf of wall street
vibe as well everything that we're
seeing from here though with the cast
involved alone you know like you just
tell me brad pitt and margot robbie and
then toby maguire like yeah tell me
those three are in this film i'm
immediately sold and margot robbie just
like she is the the best thing in the
world right now she is she is like
beautiful and insanely talented at the
same time and just immerses herself into
roles
and she looks
nutso not like she's not so just doing
her harley quinn nuts so she's doing a
different kind of nuts
and uh
i like like losing herself to the the
her vices uh and then brad pitt i think
he's supposed to be like a silent film
star and but also maybe you know other
other hats as well especially given the
it seems like he has a certain amount of
status as this trailer would suggest but
uh yeah i mean this looks really bonkers
and i love the idea of crashing these
two distinct er like they're overlapping
in time but these two distinct heroes
together because you know old hollywood
silent film you know transitioned
hockeys that's such a specific aesthetic
place to go yeah and then you have jazz
which has its own sordid debaucherous
history as well and even though this
looks way more steeped in the you know
motion picture side of hollywood i think
it's a cool juxtaposition because yeah
you have that convergence of craziness
and i feel like the music will probably
provide this interesting like backing
structure to the movie like even if it's
not necessarily about the music world i
feel like seeing what he'll do like i
just imagined the music aspects to be
just as vital the way the jazz band
keeps kind of checking in throughout
this trailer as a sort of anchor point
for all of this craziness and sort of
the underpinning the uh you know just
these the music like i feel like you
know you lose yourself to music and the
talkies were all or you know before
taki's music
movies
were so guided by and defined by you
know the music that was put under them
especially to guide the tone and
everything so yeah like being that jamie
and chazelle has that kind of reputation
for like oh yeah there's going to be
some kind of musical element i really
like the yeah blend here because you're
going to see what he gets to do with
hollywood history and it's called
babylon which reminds me of hollywood
babylon which is like a tome of
hollywood tales of debauchery xs and etc
things that back in that time you
wouldn't have associated like now we
think oh man the stars are crazy but
back then they were just as crazy in
this trailer suggests covered it up
better hold on yeah exactly
wholeheartedly well it seems like a
convergence of so many kinds of worlds
from you know these stars you know it's
like you had toby maguire who started in
a really insane 30s film i believe 30s
catholic great gatsby's 30s yes this is
boss which is
and then of course you got you know brad
pitt and margot robbie from like the
once upon a time in hollywood damien
chazelle who's combining his
like whiplash explored so much of the
music in the la la land was a tribute to
old school hollywood the more of a room
uh romanticizing in the love for it
and jazz as well so you got this great
hodgepodge of all of it being slapped
together in one and also got a bit of
that cameron crow almost famous vibe
it's really just that ending scene yeah
what is that i'm a golden number golden
god
or something like that
everything that we're getting uh on
display right now just looks eccentric
and captivating and with it just an
absolutely bad [ __ ] production design
like the art department here thrives
i i can't imagine this movie i can
imagine this movie being messy i can't
imagine it not being entertaining and
intentionally stylistic it does look
like one of those movies it's going to
be like really coked out like this looks
like it could have easily looked like
the aviator on coke yeah
exactly this transition of silent films
to talk like some people couldn't make
that transition yeah it's it's a lot
different to do dialogue than it is
dialogue
singing in the rain baby so i i can't
wait to see what's going on i hope till
mcguire actually has a a good amount of
screen time as well and i'm sure this is
going to be one of those movies that has
more of a cast than just these three
main leads who are we're being told
about like whoever that actor is that
margot robbie's interacting with at the
beginning of this film i'm like i bet
he's gonna probably be a highlight we
just don't know it yet yeah we just
don't know
and who are we gonna be the the famous
old hollywood cameo appearances by you
know old figures and who's gonna play
the old figures popping up and whatnot
yeah yeah all right guys well thank you
so much for being here i love this
trailer i did too
i wish i just could have hung out on
this set this was wild this was wild i
can't wait for december man all right
guys leave your thoughts down below
leave a like subscribe and uh before we
go let's send us
james
james listen
listen james james um i have looked you
up on urban dictionary the name james
and what it means
and let me tell you there's several
definitions but i
just found the best one yep you did
check this out
someone who is unusually
well hung dude
people with the name james are generally
known for their good looks straight
winging especially the eyes and when the
women are just simply attracted to them
you're you're a tractor beam how can you
not be attracted to you specifically you
the james james i'm shouting out right
now james where whenever we see your
shadow approaching from a you know a
wall where suddenly there's a little bit
more forward than your body it's in
those bottom region between the stomach
and the thighs you know what i'm talking
about oh yeah very well hung and creates
its own silhouette yes it does it almost
drags on the floor it's amazing it's so
big that when you see it in person
there's a drop shadow to it yep it's
insane
how
it defies
physics this is an outline yeah a white
drop shadow perfectly defined to outline
if it was glowing it's insane so james i
mean
i don't get why you should ever complain
about anything because you could use
that thing to get through life in every
aspect oh yeah
everyone knows that if you're that well
hung
no problems
no problems no problems at all
when you're that well hung
you don't gotta you're you're on the
you're on the wrong
the top rung if you were
you wouldn't know how to do that better
but because you're not no
and if you were well hung you wouldn't
even grow up to end it good because of
the fact that grower not a shower
[Laughter]
i just need to borrow some of yours
james
congratulations james you got a great
name
[Music]
you